así es ha sido un buen día para los
latinoamericanos primero con ese título
olímpico para richard a cara paz en esta
en esta prueba de ciclismo de ruta de
234 kilómetros muy difícil con ese clima
de altas de temperaturas pero allí con
un espectacular monte fuji como telón de
fondo y bueno pues el ecuatoriano supo
lograr manejar esta carrera que era
bastante larga que tenía al menos 55
ascensos y a unos 6 kilómetros de la
meta pues él logró escaparse en
solitario y pues consagrarse la medalla
de plata fue para el belga good angels
mientras que el bronce fue para el
esloveno tadej ponga char por echar
quien justamente el domingo ganó su
segundo tour de francia de forma por año
consecutivo y bueno con esta medalla de
carpas pues ya ecuador cuenta con tres
medallas olímpicas dos de ellas de oro
en su historia en la participación de
este país en en las olimpiadas y bueno y
que otros países destacaron en las
últimas horas con el oro olímpico
bueno pues justamente antes de hablarle
del oro olímpico porque si usted lo
mencionaba méxico también se llevó una
medalla de bronce en la prueba de tiro
con arco por equipos fueron alejandra
valencia y luís álvarez a quien quienes
se alzaron con esta presea tras vencer a
turquía también primera medalla esta vez
también de bronce para francia quien
abre su medallero en duda en la
categoría de menos a 60 kilos gracias a
luca merece una sorpresa esta medalla y
primera medalla de oro esta vez para los
anfitriones los japoneses también en
judo - 60 kilos fue la uis a la cato en
la judoca de 28 años quien se quedó con
esta presea dorada así que muy buen
comienzo para los japoneses
allí consagrándose en el étnico nippon
budokan que es además el templo de las
artes marciales
aquí en japonés